all right Jordan so we've had about
three days now world's edge gameplay
they've been playing pretty much
non-stop what are your thoughts so far
on the maps I say my thoughts on world's
edge have drastically changed over the
course of a few days and the very
beginning I was really sad that Kings
Canyon was gone because world's edge was
just so wide and so open and it made it
more difficult to engage in like the
fast pace close quarters combat that
Kings Canyon kind of helped emphasize
and world's edge seemed to me at least
to encourage snipers and more long-range
combat but as I kept playing it my
opinion of it has drastically changed
and now I'm really beginning to like
world's edge and I think it's mainly
because the map seems to instead of
having a focus on location that Kings
Canyon did we're finding the ideal spot
to hold up and bunker and hold the
position to let the fight come to you or
if you see someone else is already in
the right spot to go to them defeat them
and take over the location that they
have that world's edge seems to
emphasize movement a bit more and
different types of movement now there
are these underground passageways and
tunnels that you can go through or
there's all these like criss-crossing
zip lines like you don't really have
that in Kings Canyon but in world's edge
there's all these points where you can
like jump on a zipline and like halfway
across you can jump off onto another
zipline and go in another direction to
get behind someone but coming from above
as opposed to coming at them straight on
and I think that's really cool that this
map kind of funnels people to try to
either take the high ground or go the
low ground to flank people from
different directions a very different
style of play as opposed to Kings Canyon
and I'm not totally used to it yet but I
like it I think because it's so
different if that makes sense yeah I
think there's definitely a lot more
forethought you have to put it to your
fights now positioning wise just because
there's much there's so many different
biomes there's so many different areas
with that and you have to kind of take
advantage of your grounds that you have
so look again like the zip lines that
crisscross like the trains that come
along yeah you have to really think
about those things in every fight now
because Kings Canyonlands was fairly
static
sites the what they called Oh the Flyers
and leviathans yes so besides the
Leviathans stomping around and the
Flyers you know flying around once in a
while there wasn't much movement in the
map but this map is constantly on on the
move I feel like with yeah especially
because you know there's the lava areas
there's the Train
there's the crisscross zip lines there's
so many other factors to this that makes
it more interesting and you have other
options in in flights for sure yeah it
feels like the environment is like
taking part in the battle you have to
worry about lava you have to be aware of
the geyser that you can jump into that
will propel you up into the sky you have
to be worried about the fact that if
you're fighting another team on the
train tracks like the train might be
coming and could like run you over or it
could be a great way to just hop on and
easily escape because damn that thing is
fast yeah it is it's a pretty map to
like the way that's divided between like
the icy region at the top and the fire
region at the bottom with cities and
like settlements kind of like sprinkles
all throughout it like hey I like the
dichotomy the binary aspect of the map a
lot yeah the actual like biome design is
I think is really really freakin amazing
between like the ice area of Ground Zero
over there and then the lava area and
then the melted area in between where
it's just lush environments I think it's
just really well-designed when I first
dropped in a week ago it was it's been
kind of a roller coaster of emotions for
me when I first dropped in I was like
man this map is great and then after
like six games in I was like man I kind
of don't like the open grounds because
there's just a lot of huffing in there's
just a lot of running around and that
kind of attracts more third party so
you're lot of squads just kind of
roaming around trying to find places to
go and then as soon as they hear gunfire
I think it's more of a kind of a flight
attracted a situation where there's just
nothing else to do mm-hmm besides maybe
kind of the occasional loot area I think
kind of Kings can you kind of guided you
from place to place better
but then at the end I think within the
last like couple days now I've been
starting to turn back around on it and
I've been starting to like it more
because I've been getting used to that
kind of style of like okay I know where
to go now cuz I've been learning the map
better and just forcing myself to just
get from place to place quicker right
and I really liked the point that you
brought up with like as soon as you
fight someone like someone will usually
come running to like third party you
because like on Kings Canyon you could
be like walking through an area and you
would hear like a firefight off to your
left and like another off to your right
and maybe one like totally in the
distance it's like well which direction
do you want to go whereas in world's
edge because the map is just so big like
there as soon as you hear like any type
of gunshot like every squad and the
vicinity is going in that direction so
you have to kind of really decide like
is engaging this squad in front of us
worth it like do we have the right
amount of gear for taking on someone
right now knowing that the second that
we do we're probably gonna have to fight
like two or three other spots that's
definitely the the issue that I've been
having so far but crypto has been kind
of helping out with that situation with
the banner hacking hmmm where we can
kind of see how many squads are in the
area so if you you know only have one
squad in the area you can you know
safely fight them one-on-one hopefully
without getting third party otherwise if
there's like two or more than you're
likely to get a pretty bad situation
oh yeah like crypto is like the ideal
character to add for a map like this
like had his addition and Watson's been
reversed and like we were getting Watson
on this map like it is rough to find a
spot to bunker down with Watson but
having someone who can just like tell
you how many squads are in the vicinity
and where people are hiding behind like
rocks far away without actually having
to like sprint up to the rock to like
check is like it's a godsend I love it
so much it's probably like the best
purpose for him and I'm worried when we
do ultimately get Kings Canyon back like
how he's going to fit into that new meta
but currently like in world's edge like
crypto is ideal and
I I don't always like saying that
because I don't really like using him
but I feel almost naked whenever I'm in
a squad and none of us are Krypton I'm
like okay we're gonna struggle I think a
little bit yeah I feel like knowledge is
power quote comes into play here where
if you just know the battleground better
if you know how many enemies are in the
area and where they are you can just
plan your whole plan of attack much
better instead of just kind of roaming
around and trying to listen in on where
they are
so yeah crypto is very useful in these
areas I also feel like movement
characters really benefit in this meta
to with this with this map so octane
path minder just to get around the map
faster just because it is so large yeah
and to help your squad out we know what
zip lines to move around faster as well
it's just a very clutch and so I've been
using those characters a little bit more
now these days I say especially since it
I can't like say for sure but it seems
like high tier loot is just a little bit
more spread out like before on Kings
Canyon it seems like I could go to a
location and like oh we left the
location and two of us have blue body
shields and we all have two different
weapons and whatnot and now it seems
like we're landing in a spot and most of
us are fairly outfitted but we
definitely need to like get to another
spot as quickly as possible to have like
a base level of gear and weapons like
the map it was almost encouraging you
like so you can't just like stay yeah
you have to move on and like actually
like keep pushing forward to find the
things that you need that's the exact
problem that I had when I was playing in
the original drop a week ago or so and I
was telling developers this that they
probably should either just increase the
amount of common loot doesn't have to be
high to your loop but just to get on the
ground running you know something
sometimes we drop and one of us doesn't
have a shield or doesn't have a gun by
the time we get out of like a you know
sort of high tier area which is tariffs
which is kind of terrifying yeah and
like why are we so unfitted in a fairly
congested loot area and so that's one of
the things that I hope that they'll be
working on soon there's to just change
the loot situation
and I say I almost wonder and we were
kind of talking about this right
beforehand if the meta will almost
change when the vaults open because
those will presents spots where you can
get really good loot in a very specific
area and like there are three of them on
the map like no one's managed to like
get into them yet so for all we know
like world's edge will feel like a
completely different type of battlefield
like when those wallets finally open but
for now like you're right like loot is
just so scattered so having a movement
character like Pathfinder or octane it
almost seems like a necessity yeah I
feel like yeah definitely just a high
movement squad Wraith or Pathfinder to
help move the entire squad around is
very important and yeah I think the the
golden vault meta it may have a bad
impact it may have a good impact I think
depending on how they do it hopefully
it's what I'm hoping is one random loot
tick on the entire map will have one key
and it's completely random and of course
I'm pretty sure that when you pick up
this key you'll take a one slot in your
inventory and then if you get killed
they can pick up that key too so it's
fair game right but there might be some
camping involved possibly you know
people can't they buy the gold involved
saying oh they're probably gonna come by
and you know open the door for us and
then we can like you know we can attack
them afterwards yeah so that's what I
don't want I like the fact that world's
edge is like causing people to roam and
like move around and explore the map and
experiment with a bunch of things I
don't want the vaults to open and then
it suddenly becomes like half of the
squads are camping out at each of the
three vaults killing each other and then
the survivors are just waiting there for
one of the other squads that went out to
like actually find the key and approach
right one of the three vaults like that
doesn't sound fun so hopefully it
doesn't screw with the meta because
right now I do for the most part enjoy
what world's edge is and I don't wanted
to become worse so how are you liking
the train so far since you played it now
I would say the the train has led to
more like hilarious moments than actual
good moments for me my squads and I love
just like jumping on it and like
trying to melee people off and like take
control of the train more so than
actually trying to get on it to get the
loot that's usually on the Train says
it's essentially the new dropship from
like Kings Canyon it's like a semi skull
town moving yeah especially yeah and I
like it I like the fact that unlike the
dropship from Kings Canyon which like
you could only get on like when it was
approaching like its landing spot and
like extending out it's a zip lines the
Train you can essentially jump on it
whenever you want as long as you're near
it so it's kind of like this constant
presence that's on the battlefield but I
don't really have too much of an opinion
either way I think it's awesome and I
think it's fun but it seems to the most
part just kind of seem to balance into
world's edges overall meta which is the
idea of like constantly moving like
we're not even allowing you to have this
train as a spot to bunker down like
you're gonna get on and it's just gonna
keep moving yeah it's gonna keep so yeah
the verticality has been kind of hit or
miss for me specifically I think I think
is it in capital city where there's
buildings that are like 50 stories tall
but you can only access at the bottom -
yeah it's weird because like some of the
buildings you can only go like one or
two stories up some have like long
elevator shafts you can go and like
floor one two and three and then like 15
or something like that cuz you just ride
a zipline all the way to the top and
then there's that construction site
which is I want to say off the top of my
head five stories but that don't quote
me on that
it's like one of those weird things that
Kings Canyon all the buildings were
either one or two stories and maybe I
think there was one that had like three
and now we're getting all of these maps
were I can be like on a floor and my
teammates can be on like two floors
above me and then another squad can be
like on a floor above them and like
there's this added verticality to the
movement and it kind of feels almost
like a Call of Duty's blackout map that
had like the construction site it's kind
of like that moment where you have to
kind of
not only worried about the enemies in
front of you but enemies that could be
coming up from below you or from above
you and not quite sure how I like it so
much yet I feel like I feel like
characters like Pathfinder can
definitely benefit no situation oh yeah
I've been killed by quite a few paths my
name is the construction site yeah
there's also an area to the top left of
the map and forgot what the area is
called a skyhook skyhook
yeah to the northwest of skyhook there
is like a sort of secret Mountain mm-hmm
which is really cool and that kind of it
really shows off the quality of them the
map design is well in my opinion and the
just how beautiful it is really like on
Xbox one XOR obviously like you know a
maxed out PC it just looks really pretty
up there and I think they just did a
great job to dine in the map but for now
world's edge I'm happy with it
yeah they don't have to change too much
with it I agree so that's what we
thought about world's edge if you're
curious about other stuff about season 3
we have a full breakdown of all the
changes that are coming as well as an
in-depth video guide for crypto the new
recon legend and how his drone abilities
work so be sure to check both of those
out if you're jumping back into apex
with the start of season 3 meltdown we
also want to hear what you all think
about the new season as well as the new
map and the new legends so leave your
thoughts in the comment section down
below we'd love to hear your thoughts